all right tonight we have an explosive
new chapter chapter and Muller's
partisan witch hunt now we have now
entered a dangerous new phase and
there's no turning back from this it is
clear as I have been warning Muller is
out to get the president and it appears
at any cost here's what happened upon
referral from special counselor
Robert Muller the FBI has rated the
office the home and the hotel room of
Michael cone the personal attorney of
the President of the United States
now the FBI reportedly Seeds records
related to cones payment to this porn
star stormy Daniels among other items
and according to Bloomberg tonight this
all came after the Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein recommended that
the Cohn investigation be pursued by
federal prosecutors in New York now keep
in mind Cohn was never part of the Trump
administration or the Trump campaign
this is now officially an
all-hands-on-deck effort to totally
malign and if possible impeach the
President of the United States
now Muller and Rosenstein have declared
what is a legal war on the President and
a source close to President Trump
tonight is telling Fox News that
Muller's investigation is way out of
control my message tonight to Muller is
simple if you have evidence of collusion
any at all show it to us or end this
partisan investigation the country is
hanging by a thread tonight and you
don't seem to care the so called Russia
collusion investigation has now evolved
from a baseless start to a criminal
prosecution let's see a Paul Manafort
from a 12 year old payments from the
Ukraine to a payment to a porn star
named stormy Daniels now Muller and
Rosenstein they're truly fulfilling the
mainstream media's fantasy here at least
attempting to now in fact despite all of
today's major breaking news the fake
news was totally obsessed with all
Michael Cole now ultimately President
Trump was forced to address this : issue
during a meeting with military leaders
here's what he said so I just heard that
they broke into the office of one of my
personal attorneys good man
and it's a disgraceful situation it's a
total witch hunt I've been saying it for
a long time I've wanted to keep it down
we've given I believe over a million
pages worth of documents to the special
council they continue to just go forward
and here we are talking about Syria
we're talking about a lot of serious
things with the greatest fighting force
ever and I have this witch hunt
constantly going on it's a disgrace it's
frankly a real disgrace it's a an attack
on our country in a true sense it's an
attack on what we all stand for so when
I saw this and when I heard it I heard
it like you did I said that is really
now in a whole new level of unfairness
they found no collusion whatsoever with
Russia the reason they found it is there
was no collusion at all no collusion
this is the most biased group of people
these people have the biggest conflicts
of interest I've ever seen
the Attorney General made a terrible
mistake when he did this and when he
recused himself or he should have
certainly let us know if he was going to
recuse himself and we would have fused
they put a different Attorney General
and we've had that hanging over us now
from the very very beginning and yet the
other side they don't even bother
looking and the other side is where
there are crimes and those crimes are
obvious lies under oath all over the
place
emails that are knocked out that are
acid-washed and deleted nobody's ever
seen 33,000 emails are deleted after
getting a subpoena for Congress and
nobody bothers looking at that the
president is exactly right this is a
huge massive double standard you think
Hillary Clinton's attorneys had their
offices raided during this email
investigation not a chance
he think Hillary Clinton's lawyers were
they raided after it was determined she
bought and paid for that phony Russian
dossier to influence the general
election not
chance no investigation any raids any
arrests after the massive Faiz abuse
allegations were exposed not a single
chance
were there any raids any arrests after
Hillary Clinton
we know she obstructed justice we know
she deleted 33,000 emails we know she
deleted all of them and used the
acid-wash that the president was talking
about bleach pit and then had the
devices busted up with hammers anybody
do anything there not a chance
everything we've been telling you about
this two-tier justice system we don't
have equal justice under the law it
should be in the minds of every American
citizen tonight Robert Muller is so far
beyond his mandate this is now spiraling
out of control everything that we have
warned you about is now coming to
fruition and Muller has ostensibly
tonight declared war against the
President of the United States clearly
his objective is to remove him from
office now I told you and I told anyone
who will listen
Muller's team is corrupt starting with
him and it has been from the beginning
now show us the evidence of collusion or
this investigation needs to end
ultimately Muller's runaway
investigation can all be traced back to
one unfortunate act the president
alluded to this the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions recusing himself from the
Russia investigation leaving rod
Rosenstein let's see Muller's best
friend calm ease best friend McCabe's
best friend to act in his behalf he is
basically the Attorney General and
tonight as this investigation is now
spiraling out of control it is time to
start making moves perhaps maybe even
like congressman mark meadows suggested
impeaching Rosenstein and we'll explain
that later in the program and this leads
us directly by the way to our next story
the slow release of these subpoenaed
documents from the Justice Department to
the House Judiciary Committee the house
Intel committee regarding the FBI's
Clinton email investigation and the
potential FISA abuses during the
presidential election the Attorney
General jeff Sessions appointed a US
Attorney to oversee the delivery of more
than 1.2 million documents so far the
Justice Department has offered three
thousand and six hundred that's it why
are they slow walking why aren't they
handing over what Congress has
subpoenaed and it is their
constitutional right to look at visa vie
oversight according to a new report
tonight from Sarah Carter quote some
lawyers are now saying the do J's
appointment is nothing but political
theater to avoid contempt of Congress
makes no statement are crucial if we're
going to find answers about how the
Obama Justice Department under Loretta
Lynch and the FBI director James Comey
handled will rather mishandled the
Clinton investigation these documents
will shed light on how Hillary was
cleared of all charges I've never heard
of an exoneration before an
investigation before and I doubt any of
you have as well these documents could
show how the FISA system was used to spy
in a presidential campaign and how they
lied to FISA Court justice why won't the
Justice Department release the
unredacted FBI memo that Devon newness
of the house Intel committee has been
demanding what was used of course to
justify the entire Russia collusion
investigation to begin with now this is
more than frustrating and just one more
example that we now live in a country
with a two-tier justice system this is
what I've been warning you about the FBI
is more than capable tracing a Russia
collusion investigation somehow to a
porn star and the door of Donald Trump's
personal attorney Michael Kohn but the
Justice Department of the United States
of America is slow walking and purposely
not even releasing documents they have
in their possession that has been
subpoenaed by the United States Congress
the Judiciary Committee the Intel
committee it's shameful this should
alarm every person watching this
broadcast tonight and we'll have a lot
more on that in a few minutes Alan
Dershowitz Eric Carter Gregg Jarrett are
all here but the media while they're
obsessing over Michael Kohn yeah there
are really important stories to bring to
you over the weekend according to
multiple multiple reports on the ground
an anti Assad suburb of Damascus was
subject to a deadly chemical weapons
attack horrific video captured from the
scene it shows men it shows women
it shows children gasping for air
foaming at the mouth with many laying on
the ground dead from what appears to be
yet another gas attack from the Assad
regime against their own people and as
we
speak the president once again weighing
his options in Syria and here's what the
president said about this earlier today
we're gonna make a decision tonight or
very shortly thereafter and you'll be
hearing the decision but we can't let
atrocities like we all witnessed and you
can see that and it's horrible we can't
let that happen
in our world we can't let that happen
especially when we're able to because of
the power of the United States because
of the power of our country we're able
to stop it we have a lot of options
militarily and we'll we'll be letting
you know pretty soon probably after the
fact now according to general mattis all
options were on the table including a
military response in Syria earlier today
the president said he would make a
decision in the next 24 to 48 hours
Russia and Iran are now coming to
Assad's defense denying Assad actually
launched the chemical attack and as I
have said many times on this program
just one more reason this flawed Iranian
nuclear deal needs to be canceled
immediately
I believe the president will do that
soon as the president said Russia should
also be paying a big price for
supporting Assad including new sanctions
and political restrictions and of course
this comes a little over a year after
President Trump remember he launched
dozens of cruise missiles heavily
damaging an airbase in Syria after a
similar gas attack in 2017 and sadly
this also comes after years of complete
and utter total inaction from the Obama
administration
remember Obama's imaginary red line in
the sand and the price we've now paid
this goes back to 2012 we have
communicated in no uncertain terms with
every player in the region that that's a
red line for us and that there would be
enormous consequences if we start seeing
movement on the chemical weapons front
or the use of chemical weapons that
would that would change my calculations
significantly now of course the redline
was crossed Obama's Bluff was called and
the region fell into complete and utter
chaos with many subsequent gas attacks
to follow and in 2013 the Obama
administration struck an utterly
laughable diplomatic agreement with
Assad which guaranteed the removal of a
hundred percent of the chemical weapons
from Syria okay I guess then Icahn as it
turns out murderous dictators are not
exactly trustworthy and Obama's policy
in Syria ended up being a total failure
left to the president now to rectify so
with action now imminent in Syria
tonight we'll bring you any breaking
developments as they happen also tonight
in an attempt to get ahead of James
commis impending book tour the former
attorney general Loretta Lynch is now
speaking out trying to explain some of
well her unusual and potentially illegal
actions during the FBI's Clinton email
investigation back in 2016
remember when Lynch directed the FBI
director James Comey to call Clinton's
criminal investigation a quote matter
not an investigation and he listened now
take a look at how she now tries to
explain this away all while throwing
poor James Cole me under the bus before
his book tour this was an interview with
NBC News this was a very sensitive
investigation as everyone knew and the
issue when he and I sat down at that
time which I I think was early in the
fall of 2015 was whether or not we were
ready as a department to confirm an
investigation going on when we typically
do not confirm or deny investigations
into anything with rare exceptions so
Comey says you want to call it the
Clinton matter he once called the
Clinton investigation to the extent
though that he noted it that it bothered
him did he go to you and question your
your credibility with regard to the
Clinton case well yeah I can tell you
that you know it was a meeting like any
other that we that we had had when we
talked about the issues and we had a
full and open discussion about it they
didn't raise any concern and and
concerns were not raised all right we'll
have more Loretta Lynch's comments later
in the show